[Music]
made it through the first leg of the
trip it is now 9:00 a.m. I have been up
for quite a few hours and there are no
snacks that I could buy because
everything is wrapped in plastic hi I'm
Marie McCrory with National Geographic
Travel recently I took a trip to Belize
and I challenged myself to do it without
any single-use plastics this is how I'm
taking national Geographics planet or
plastic pledge and putting it into
action and Belize was actually a really
great place to try this there government
recently announced that they're gonna be
banning major single-use plastics
avoiding single-use plastics in everyday
life is already pretty hard but doing it
while you're traveling can be even
harder it means you have to avoid things
like plastic water bottles and those
shampoos at hotels and pretty much
anything you can eat in an airport
here's what I chose to replace the
single-use plastics that I would
normally be using a reusable grocery bag
bamboo utensils a glass straw
collapsible Tupperware our soap and bar
shampoo two reusable water bottles and a
stereo pump there is so much I learned
from this experience but here are four
things that I think are really important
first thing you have to ask got a straw
on my first night and my lastly having a
glass straw is not helpful if you forget
to say no straw please I ended up only
using two pieces of single-use plastic
on this trip and both of them were
straws which was surprising because I
thought they were gonna be the most
avoidable second thing is you have to
research the water situation I couldn't
drink the tap water in Belize and I
worried that if I couldn't purify my
water I would end up using dozens of
plastic water bottles I was so relieved
that all the lodges I stayed in and a
lot of restaurants had purified water
stations
the third tip is that collapsible
Tupperware is definitely underrated
turns out it was great for carrying
around snacks and grabbing food to go
when I was in a rush my captain waited a
[Music]
little container for us so we can hurry
on our way because we're running late
for an explain the last tool tip is you
don't always need tools you can skip
single-use plastics without replacing
them by saying no to an airplane snack
skipping a sample at an ice cream shop
or asking for a cone instead of a cup
towards the end of my trip I got a
reminder of why cutting back on plastics
was so important I was paddleboarding in
the port endorsed Marine Reserve and
noticed a bunch of plastics caught up in
the roots of the mangrove okay well can
save all the plastic that's back there
but did get this one big piece that was
stuck behind some branches it was pretty
hard to see and I knew it was only a
tiny fraction of what ends up in her
oceans in the end I avoided 79 pieces of
single-use plastic and only used two on
this week-long trip this experience
reminded me that you don't have to be
perfect even if you mess up along the
way doing something makes a difference
[Music]